ge serait rami m'occuper de la pelouse
voilà autrement
[Musique]
on dit que l'amour n'a pas de couleur
d'âge ni de religion pas de logique
baden de temps plein elsa vous nous dire
après si vous êtes célibataire ou pas 6e
jean michel mr et votre style à mai
laissez lui sa chance
oui surtout paix on dit souvent femme
qui rit à moitié dans son lit et moi qui
ai bien jean michel maire vous allez
essayer d'avoir pour l'instant la moitié
des lives et de la faire rire en une
minute on va mettre un chrono
[Musique]
il est différent
j'ai tout seul
je suis comme
crim
est ce que c'est votre style bah oui je
pense ballard est ce que c'est votre
style ou pas esthétiquement comme ça
c'est votre style ou pas j'arrive pas à
regarder au delà de deux ans de plus que
moi
voilà là c'est surtout quand on a deux
sens entre c'est que cette robe de folie
dames et messieurs les tirs amis un
petit pot de confiture sa carte au elsa
déjà je trouve sublime franchement
absolument magnifique pour la faire rire
oui mais je commence ma petit problème
pour la deuxième partie après que voilà
et donc je connais ta carrière beaucoup
mieux que tu ne croyais t'as vu en tout
cas ce que je me suis souvent enseigner
je sais notamment que ta chaîne
s'appelle eden voilà je sais qu'elle
adore gambader dans le jardin donc si on
arrive à trouver un petit truc entre
nous je ne serai jamais occupé de sa
pelouse
autrement mère s'appelle mardi
[Applaudissements]
avant
c'est gagnable vous allez me le dire lui
faire un petit bisou
merci à ces notions mecheria le fait
divers - j
pour toi si tu
et y croit
pour tous
on
[Musique]
elsa souks et avec tout ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]